non-minimalists
how can i figure out the difference
between having a great relationship
and settling for an easy comfortable
relationship
this is a good question yeah that's a
great question because sometimes we
confuse the two right
we confuse well this is kind of in fact
you know what man the reason
that i know bec stayed in in her her
marriage her and i were both in
eight-year relationships she was married
but before
we were together and i was married
before she was together obviously and
we were both in these eight-year
relationships and i think the reason
they lasted
as long as they lasted is because they
were easy
yeah and uncomfortable yeah it's like
well i'm following this trajectory i'm
going with the flow
and this is what i'm supposed to do
and so my pithy answer is this easy
relationships
atrophy simple relationships grow
amen it's about making that distinction
we're working on the uh the soundtrack
for our second documentary right now and
one of the songs was called take it easy
and i asked uh
i asked nate if you could change the
title to take it simple we we have a
we have a uh uh essay on our website
from years ago but it's
still one of my favorites it's i
accidentally there was like a ups or
fedex guy dropping off a package one day
and
in ohio you hear people all the time so
take it easy take it easy it's just like
a
you know it's like saying goodbye right
yeah well for whatever reason like
something that day i was writing about
simplicity or something and as he left i
said all right take it simple
and i'm like wait a minute what and and
ever since then i've actually signed my
emails with take it simple
yeah man because it's easy is
just that it's easy it's unintentional
but simple
is intentional it's deliberate it's
curated a forest fire
is easy but a a beautiful display
of fireworks is simple yeah i mean for
me man to have a good relationship it
needs a couple things
it needs uh it needs respect and it
needs support
and you know i don't sit there and
um analyze every relationship and list
them out from one to ten okay here's my
here's my most supportive and respectful
relationship
all the way to my least supportive if
they include those two things
then uh i'm usually okay so my pithy
answer is
if a relationship is missing support or
respect
it's guaranteed to be pernicious
guaranteed
and that's really what i look at when i
look at relationships
is is this a relationship where
we both show support we both show
respect
we both are giving to this us box we're
taking as we need
and and and uh that usually for me means
a
a great relationship and and not just in
intimate relationships either it's your
relationship with podcast shops
absolutely friends with family you have
to show that support and respect in
order for that to grow